hi there today we're looking at
processing megapixel images with deep
attention sampling models by Angela
Scott aeropolis and Francois flurry so
this is another paper that I saw the
talk of at ICML and it's a pretty cool
idea is pretty simple and apparently it
works very well so consider the
following image here of a street
situation and ask yourself if a
self-driving car sees this what are the
kind of things it needs to be aware of
so of course one of the things it needs
to be aware of is like the road the cars
and so on but also what's in circled in
red here the street sign and the street
sign especially is important because
there's a number on it and you want to
see what the number is otherwise you
won't be able to adjust your speed so if
this is now a really large image so if
the camera camera is really good and the
dimensions of this image are really
large then current machine learning
methods have a problem because current
machine learning methods kind of go up
to maybe something like 200 by 200
pixels or the current M imagenet models
some downsample ants on so if this is
much larger than this what current
machine learning models would do is they
would simply down sample that I could
compress this size just compress it a
bit and so on and by that as you see
here on the right if the original patch
in the image you could you know you
could just cut it out enlarge it it
would look like this
if you compress the whole image the same
patch would now look like this blurred
so in the bottom half you'd be able to
recognize the number in the top half you
wouldn't so as standard CNN might be
able to recognize the road and the car
still at the lower resolution but not
the speed sign
what we want is a method that can
selectively pay attention to parts of
the image that it finds interesting and
then look at those parts in full detail
while basically deciding to discard
other parts completely such as the sky
here so this paper is one that does this
and does so in a very efficient manner
so the basic premise is very simple all
right I'm going to show it on this on
the same image so what you do is first
you actually compress the image so this
image would become a smaller image right
so here maybe this is one thousand by
two thousand you compress it down to
maybe 100 by 200 still the same image
but compressed on here's the road here's
a bunch of trees I'm very good at
drawing trees and here's this street
sign and here is a car and here is
another car all right
so and there's a sky up here so now what
you do is on this smaller version you
classify every location in it I guess
you could classify you could subsample
but you want to classify every single
location on it on how interesting is it
and what they do is they take this and
just put it through what they call an
attention network which is just this
it's just a neural network in their case
it's a CNN that for each location here
for each blue location outputs a
function a of a and let's call it a X Y
at coordinates x and y of this image X
okay I
this is stupid notation that's a of X so
the image is X at
coordinates IJ right so all of these
blue things here our eyes and Jays
different eyes and Jays and then does
this gives you now if you normalize
correctly so if you normalize over all
the A's and I J and I J if you normalize
this gives you a distribution over this
image so if we look at it in like 1d
this gives you like a distribution not a
continuous one in this case a discrete
one how interesting is each patch and at
the end if you have this distribution so
let's finish here what you want to do is
you want to say which are the most
interesting location so this one's
pretty high and these are very high so
that might correspond to over here that
might correspond to some location so
this location is very high and these
locations are very interesting and only
in these locations you take them out and
then only those you process and full
resolution so you might have extracted
let's say four patches so now you have
four of these patches and each of them
individually you run through a second
neural network which is called another
CNN which is called F the feature
network so the feature network will take
a patch and output a vector of features
right so you'll feed those in and output
the vector of features and then what you
do is you simply your final output which
they call G let me colorize this so G
which is
so G is now the final output
that's not ecology let's call it Oh
output is you sum over all the patches
you have extracted done here or so the
patch number P over all your patches and
you sum these features F of patch P
right and P might be at location IJ
let's put I J here so IJ in then the
extracted patches and you way each
feature by how much attention it got at
that location alright so it looks more
complicated than it is what you do is
you simply determine these features by
using this neural network only at the
position where this neural network says
are interesting then you get the
features from the interesting positions
and you basically just weigh them by how
much attention they they got in the
attention distribution and that will be
your final output of the network and it
makes intuitive sense like one network
decides what is interesting the other
network decides what are we going to do
with the interesting things in this in
this image and the cool thing about this
is you can basically decide how many of
these patches here how many you want to
extract you can decide at what
resolution you want to process this
image and all of this are parameters
that you set by how much time you have
for computation and how much memory you
have for your computation so that's
pretty cool pretty model you can scale
up and scale down and the another cool
thing is the theoretical guarantees that
they give so basically here
they prove that the way they do it
especially by extracting the patch
especially if they've a non-biased sorry
especially if they have sampling without
replacement is that if they weigh the
things correctly and if they do the
things correctly they show that this is
actually an unbiased estimator of the
true neural network if you were to
evaluate on the full image basically on
each patch in full resolution so I'm
only taking the ones where the attention
focuses is an unbiased estimator and not
only is it an unbiased estimator it is
in fact the estimator with the smallest
variance and that's what they prove here
means so the minimum variance estimator
and this is this is pretty pretty
interesting pretty cool and works pretty
well they also show how to derive the
gradient update when you train with this
attention sampling so now you train your
neural you train your machine learning
system not on the whole image but only
on a sub set of the image patches but it
still behaves in expectation as if you
were to train on the entire images so
pretty neat so here they show how this
compares to full CNN in this case we
have the full CNN where the picture is
simply down sampled and then classified
and this is what's called megapixel
amnesty and megapixel amnesty you have a
large image and you put three digits in
there that are the same for example 5 5
5 from the M&S data set you put two
random digits others like 2 3 and you
put also a bunch of noise noise patches
somewhere so the task is to recognize
which is the dominant digit here in this
case it would be five right two five
five where was the other one five here
so if you give this to a regular CNN you
see it does about this well this is the
training loss here training loss and
this is the test loss and it takes this
much time right time very Parker and
this much time to evaluate sorry if you
now use this attention sampling and as I
said you can actually modulate how many
patches you want to take so as you go
down you take more patches we would
expect it to take more time that's
exactly what happens you see for example
down here in the test error if you take
five patches per image it takes very
little time but the error and the error
is still better than the if you use the
CNN simply because you can now pay
attention to details much more as you
use more patches your test error drops
it also your training loss they drop so
using more patches will actually give
you a better and better and better
performing model but you sacrifice a
little bit of time but still not never
as as slow as with the full with that
with the CNN so even though it's a
downsampled CNN right so that is very
interesting and very cool that not only
do they beat the the baseline in terms
of error but also a lot in terms of
speed if you look at what the model does
as it learns here you see it for a given
image this is always the same image from
the data set at the beginning they have
actually marked where the relevant three
relevant digits are in the picture with
a red circle so if you look at how over
the training of this model how this
distribution evolves is pretty
interesting yellow basically means high
attention
the beginning you have high attention
for everywhere in the image right and
then as you go on and on and on you see
for example here it pays attention to
all the locations where basically where
there is something in the image right
this could be one of these three digits
but it could also be one of the digits
that it's trying to that is trying to
distract the model like the false digits
or the noise patches and as you go more
and more and more it really learns to
only pay attention to the irrelevant
digits and then classify those at full
resolution so this really shows the this
this kind of attention distribution
learns something very meaningful they do
more experiments on two data sets namely
this is a histopathology data set right
here where the goal is I think to
recognize this epithelial cells this
type of cell and you can see the this
here is the baseline and this here is
the new method and the baseline
basically what it does is it does a
similar thing namely it processes the
image in patches but it processes every
single patch maybe in succession but it
still processes every single patch where
the attention sampling only processes
the patches that the attention sampling
distribution suggests and this other
objector set here is a street sign
dataset that you saw at the beginning
right here and the the again I think
this is the baseline and this is the
attention size so both learn to pay
attention to the street signs but again
the attention sampling much more
efficient so here you see the baseline
the attention sampling performance is
similar in terms of test error but if
you look at how much time the baseline
uses per sample and how much memory and
then compare this to the attention
sampling you see that they save at least
an order of magnitude in time and memory
and the same thing goes for the street
sign data set
you see test error here and then test
error is similar for the attention
sampling but again time memory much much
lower so the attention sampling is
faster and it is more memory efficient
than the baseline and that makes it
makes it easy to process these megapixel
images even on here they say process
megapixel images in a single CPU or GPU
and that really I like this because it
kind of brings the research back to
let's say regular people or maybe
universities that don't have as much
money as large companies and so all in
all very cool paper very neat
experiments they have a lot in the
appendix
check it out where they show their
attention distribution in these images
their theoretical analysis is pretty
easy to follow if you want to check that
out and with that thanks for listening
and bye bye